he's the quarterback and Heintzman
Trophy winner Lamar Jackson he brought
the hardware in with him they'll never
be able to take that away from you the
rest of your life
Heisman Trophy winner when did it sink
in um you know it still hasn't nothing
when I go back and sit down my teammates
and you know have fun with those guys
didn't really sink in
there's no without them I won't have
this trophy when that envelope is being
open what do you think uh hardest found
you know um I thought I caught a heart
attack you know oh I was sewing shot you
know he said my name I was like man no
way you gotta call someone else I gotta
call someone else up and would you have
been okay if they said to Sean Watson
and I to me clapping for him like I
don't wanna hear no I heard it apartment
different for me um but actually had my
name it was like no way cuz I wasn't I
wasn't I wasn't thinking I was gonna
winner on win this war you know cuz it
was so many great guys you know going
against dumb man as finalists it was
like telling oh I can't even explain it
but the speech itself how much did you
prepare um you know at first it was a
written speech you know
but then i sorry enough it was like man
I could I couldn't you say two things I
just had to come from heart with it but
you it overwhelmed you you did you know
um just speaking upon the people who who
really helped me win this award hold on
do and to have your mom out there it was
it was you know a dream come true
because I always wanted to spotlight on
her you know I always wanted people to
know her she put into it and with me and
my brother and um sister but what came
to mind when you're up there and you're
talking about your mom I need some help
I need someone else I'm here to talk
[ __ ] curse what mom should have given
the speech she should have you know um
at first I think one of my team told my
teammate James her numb Brandon Radcliff
they jinx me in a group message you know
because I had exam that they do and I
was like man I'm I need help with this
is am
like it was like you thinking about exam
you um about you up manually up with the
husband award I'm like so way you know
man it was like don't cross stage I'm
like mango cross oh we're here
so they geez me almost cry but here you
are playing quarterback yes you're not
overwhelmed playing quarterback but
you're overwhelmed standing 80,000
people don't bother you but a couple of
million bother you when you're up there
where you know is definitely have one
helmet you don't really have to talk um
you only have to talk to your teammates
you know um and tell them about defenses
that's coming and stuff like that you
know making checks and things like that
but you actually had to spotlight on you
you know not a helmet you not an action
doing anything you just speaking it's
different could you have done better if
you had your helmet on I probably could
I probably made it as a joke he's Lamar
Jackson the Louisville quarterback
joining us who did you hang out with on
Saturday night after you won um actually
no um deshaun Watson came out of room um
make away from him man he's from in the
sky man he is character he's funny mom
gentleman uh he was telling me a lot of
positive things you know he came out of
room too and he knew huge at telling me
man have fun in college no I'm gonna
consider certain amount of time have fun
with it so well he stopped by after he
won the Heisman a couple years ago here
he's sitting in that same exact seat and
I told him your life is going to change
and it changed in a way that nobody ever
thought would change are you ready for
this even though you have to go back to
college but now you're marked man yeah
you know uh momma had to be sending
house a lot more than I did before um
can't really go to the store how I
wanted to how I usually do um you know
had a couple Louisville fans you know
coming to me but you know it's all love
but now that I'm here I know it's gonna
be even crazy
what are you 1990 man that's a lot yes
sir
what two years ago if I told you you're
gonna win the Heisman Trophy well but
you said hopefully
I'm sure hahaha but to have it now it
was like I want this betting that you
know from being young and saying you
gonna win is this different thing and to
actually um you know be a finalist what
it's like man is hoping one of these
guys went into winners for
who's the quarterback that you admire
the most Oh know how to say Michael fit
no arm I always watched him play you
know growing up since 2004
no he played for Falcons I like me fast
you know he'll that's right and I used
to go out there and play you see faster
than you
all right now no one over the hole right
now you're faster right never you're
faster than him
it depends what are you running if
you're running a 4000 no you know what
was your signature moment this year
where you you just said wow I'm doing
something kind of special you know I
already know you know cuz I tried to
make every game special no um I told my
teammates before the year began I was
trying to UM lead on tape the seniors
out on top but what about if I said let
me show one highlight to America what
would be the highlight no no my um I
would say a pass play you know to Gemara
staples no it was a post pattern during
ec and she stayed game um it was a
safety coming down coming back on his
back and co he casinos running on rear
out right in front of him so people
thinking ball going to Co he Cassini
when she hit Jamar out of his chest it
was a bullet passing he made it to me
sketch for this assess but you picked a
pass instead of a run oh yeah you know I
don't really try to develop myself too
much noiz all about the team after game
and if it's about my teammates not me
but you also have every running
quarterback once the proved he can pass
and passing quarterbacks I want to prove
they can run a little bit you know it's
um you know it's part of the game you
know people always try to dumb you down
for certain things you know either when
they see you unless you're running the
ball they want to say oh he's not
efficient you know passing the ball or
they see your great passer oh he's
really slow and running so this is all
the footballs Hawkman a favorite team
growing up Dallas Cowboys oh we could
make little take away the playoffs ain't
got a three order back Lamar they got
their quarterback no I actually went on
I went on a visit up gonna be on
Mississippi State when that was in home
college I see no you thought about going
there oh yeah you know I was actually
talking to that he's a great guy so I
love Dallas dude is they offer your
scholarship yes sir where where did it
come down to if it wasn't Louisville
you're going to wear
no I was talking about Florida but
whatever on school gave me opportunity
you know a lot of schools will offer me
four different positions Florida didn't
want you to the quarterback anyone
duration he wanted me as a quarterback I
was talking about race room who didn't
want you to said quarterback I'm Georgia
no George off of me no difference corny
to call me all I own are you know this
story that got a lot of publicity
nationally when you came on the show and
I talked to you about your mom and she
she helped you with your career but she
wouldn't put the pads on you and go out
back yeah you know she seen me Willie
and my little brother you could say I'm
just running him over and stuff like
that how old is your brother you're
younger to me but I'm a lot taller than
him from okay you were romping him up in
the backyard yeah I had to tell my
little brother and your mom did what she
put up and she put the pants on that I
was doing him in and she was like do it
to me so I'm her being a woman I was
like come on no um I was taking on the
challenge you know she was hauling me
doing so I like come on whatever so I
ran the ball and she smacked me yeah is
that the hardest you've been here um
yeah yeah yeah yeah most people don't
get their hands on you though yeah you
know I try to keep that away you know
outside stay healthy what it was the the
photograph at Syracuse you don't yeah
yeah you know I wasn't really think
anyone go you know so far you know but
then that went viral I mean everybody
looked at it you know that photograph I
think was America's saying oh let me
keep an eye on this guy yeah yeah you
can say that you know man I told all my
teammates man cuz you know them God no
no you owe a lot to the photographers
what you owe that yeah yeah you could
say that too but I mean not to me man
that's an iconic picture that probably
wouldn't happen if you wouldn't block
the guy you know he had he had he turned
his block you know he missed that number
22 corner and oh yeah he made screwed up
no he actually helped no he did help it
was a success you know he helped me out
when he missed that block he made up for
not number eight who was chasing me from
behind so he ought to probably got
tackled before this so I would autism
our estate was in a great photographer
Ella man that photograph is awesome next
the great photographs I've ever seen
where's the trophy go after this to my
mother
yeah yes sir she gonna put it like on
the kitchen table or I'm nights nowhere
to eat officer boom you know she she she
know she's been pretty good um you know
putting my wars away so I don't know you
you talked about you lose your
grandmother and your dad the same day
yeah it was crazy I was you know I was
hurt you know I was crying a lot you
know my father passed but um my mom
found out my grandma passed you know
like probably probably an hour later
actually and she told me no she won't
everyone find out about it so she like
Lamar you know come here I like yes
ma'am she was like no um don't cry but
you know my own grandmother that's fast
so I was like don't cry no um but hunter
you owe eight years old oh my god eight
years old you know I love them to death
no um I still be um you know trying to
make them happy
you know I'm just I'm blessed right now
beautiful so mom says you can't cry you
can't cry yeah you know I gotta suck it
up listening to my mother who gets the
second Heisman you're gonna win you know
haha my mother he gets both of them I
mean if hopefully if you know if I'm
come back you know I've here in New York
my mother gets it again you know I have
a Heisman vote you wanna know who I
voted for my mother that night I would
have voted for your mother um oh no I
voted for Baker Mayfield three hmm you
too
deshaun Watson one you know I felt the
same way you know um you know I felt
like he got robbed laughter you know I
was looking forward to her on the song
winning that man he had a tremendous
sophomore year you know he was young
just like I was nineteen years old yeah
and I thought he did a great job last
year and to him for him to come back
this year I was like oh this hunger win
you know no doubt in my mind
I'll just happy to be up there and talk
to him he's a great kid too yeah he is
he cool yeah and it was difficult
because I think you started out so great
yeah finished bad yeah it was horrible
I hated it yeah hates the right now and
I and I didn't know if if that was gonna
hurt you and I looked at maybe deshaun
Watson and I said I'm gonna take two
years combined mm-hmm and I just thought
you know you're playing for the national
chain
kinship perhaps again and you have one
loss um so I voted for him mm-hmm so I
just want you to know yeah you know I
haven't I have no problem out of order
for myself you know um I have no problem
with it you know out of what if autumn
guys you know cousin guy was great you
know even Cabrera you know plan all the
positions and he's doing a lot for a
team you know DD he out running
defenders making defenders look bad and
bake man bake his crazy he's crazy nice
I love my quarterback
you see goofy he can dance me that's my
boy man can he dance better than you
he got me oh really he got me beat me in
the [ __ ] arm and he he got me beat
man and shut out a beat he is the
Heisman Trophy winner good luck heading
back home Thank You Sun life's not gonna
be the same yes or no everybody gonna
keep an eye on you yes sir I'm gonna
watch what you do everything you do yes
sir just so you know that all right you
got mom there yes sir absolutely
I'm gonna keep you straight hey congrats
thank you swing season see you next
season here in New York
Lamar Jackson the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience
[Music]